>>> FROM CHICAGO AND ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY THE NEWLY VACCINATED
ARE HOPING TO HIT THE OPEN ROAD
THIS SUMMER.
AND IF YOU NEED A NEW OR USED
CAR, BRACE YOURSELF FOR A BIT OF
STICKER SHOCK.
YOU SEE A WORLDWIDE SHORTAGE OF
ONE TYPE OF COMPUTER CHIP IS
WREAKING HAVOC ON THE AUTOMOTIVE
SUPPLY CHAIN.
AND THIS IS HAPPENING JUST AS
DEMAND IS INCREASING.
THE RESULT, RECORD HIGH PRICES
FOR NEW AND USED CARS, AND TOUGH
CHOICES DOWN THE ROAD.
>> TO SOME DEGREE, IT LOOKS LIKE
MAYBE I'M GOING OUT OF BUSINESS.
>> ANY OTHER YEAR STEPHEN WADE
WOULD BE WORRIED TO SEE HIS 40
ACRES OF CAR DEALERSHIP SPACE SO
EMPTY.
INSTEAD HE'S OVERJOYED.
>> I'VE HAD THE BEST YEAR IN THE
HISTORY OF MY WHOLE LIFE, THE
BEST YEAR FINANCIALLY.
>> AND HOW MANY YEARS HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING THIS?
>> LOOK AT THIS GREAT HAIR.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS ALL MY
LIFE.
>> IT'S ALL THANKS TO AN ONGOING
SHORTAGE OF COMPUTER CHIPS.
YOU SEE, IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A
CENTURY SINCE CARS WERE JUST
FOUR STIFF WHEELS AND A CHASSIS.
>> THE FIRST CHEVROLET TO OFFER
WIRELESS APPLE CAR PLAY AND
ANDROID AUTO.
>> NOW THEY'RE LUXURIOUS COMFORT
MACHINES INFUSED WITH TOP
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT THE SEMICONDUCTOR CHIPS
UNDERLYING THAT CONVENIENCE ARE
ALSO KEY TO COMPUTERS AND
WIRELESS DEVICES, FOR WHICH
DEMAND SHOT UP DRAMATICALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
>> RIGHT NOW IT IS A BIG
PROBLEM.
>> CISCO CHAIRMAN AND CEO CHUCK
ROBBINS THIS WEEK.
>> SEMICONDUCTORS GO IN
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING.
WHAT HAPPENED IS WHEN COVID HIT,
I THINK EVERYONE THOUGHT THE
DEMAND SIDE WAS GOING TO DECLINE
SIGNIFICANTLY, AND IN FACT WE
SAW THE OPPOSITE.
>> GLOBAL CAR MAKERS HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO PAUSE OR REDUCE
PRODUCTION.
FORD'S F-150 AND CHEVY TRAIL
BLAZER ARE AMONG DOZENS OF
POPULAR BRANDS AFFECTED.
>> WE GENERALLY SEE SALES UPTICK
IN MAY AND THEN JULY IS ANOTHER
BIG MONTH AND AUGUST.
>> JESSICA CALDWELL SAYS THIS
SHORTAGE MEANS YOU'RE LIKELY TO
MAKE CONCESSIONS ON YOUR NEXT
CAR.
>> PARTICULARLY THE F-150.
BECAUSE THEY SELL SO MANY, THERE
ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS TO
CONFIGURE THAT VEHICLE.
IN TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE TO SCALE
BACK, YOU CAN'T NECESSARILY
OFFER EVERYTHING TO CONSUMERS.
>> WADE SAYS WHEN IT COMES TO
CHEVY SILVERADOS, HE USUALLY HAS
AROUND 75 TO OFFER.
RIGHT NOW HE ONLY HAS FOUR.
AND OF ALL THE CARS YOU SEE ON
HIS LOTS, HALF ARE ALREADY SOLD
BY THE TIME THEY ARRIVE.
SO CAR BUYERS, HE WARNS, SHOULD
EXPECT A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE
THIS SUMMER.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING BE PATIENT,
BE FLEXIBLE, AND BE WILLING TO
DIG A LITTLE DEEPER?
>> WITH A LITTLE BIT OF PATIENCE
AND UNDERSTANDING, WE COULD ALL
WORK TOGETHER SO THE SYSTEM
WORKS AND IT CAN WORK WITH THE
CUSTOMER AND IT CAN WORK FOR THE
DEALER.
>> NOW, LOOK, PREDICTIONS ARE
THIS SHORTAGE COULD LAST THE
REST OF THE YEAR AND POSSIBLY
INTO 2022.
WADE SAYS THERE IS ONE SMALL
SILVER LINING FOR CUSTOMERS.
YOU CAN NOW GET MORE BANG FOR
YOUR BUCK ON A TRADE-IN.
THEY'RE APPARENTLY BEING VALUED
AT A PREMIUM BY AS MUCH AS 20%
BUT AT THE SAME TIME YOU'RE LESS
LIKELY TO GET A DEAL ON A
PURCHASE BECAUSE DEMAND IS SO
HIGH AND SUPPLY IS LOW.
>> I'M GLAD I BOUGHT A CAR LAST
YEAR, AND ALSO PATIENCE DOES NOT
WORK WELL SADLY FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> AT A CAR DEALERSHIP, IF YOU
NEED TO GET OUT AND GET BACK ON
THE ROAD, HOW LONG CAN YOU WAIT?
>> AND HERE'S THE THING, THIS
SITUATION IS ONLY GETTING WORSE.
THE WORST IS GET TO COME WHEN IT
COMES TO CARS AND CHIP
SHORTAGES.
>> BECAUSE OF THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUE, PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO LOOK INTO
THIS IN FEBRUARY.
IT WILL BE A LONG TIME BEFORE
THE U.S. COU